[Music]
[Applause]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
they watch the show and they look for
mistakes I know not only way it's so sad
so far hundreds and hundreds of
challengers not one winner why Andy
we don't make mistake we don't make
mistakes well tonight a fan from Ecuador
named Juan says he thinks he caught a
mistake he says it happened when I was
talking to actor Dean Norris take a look
at this there is a Mexican version this
is true of Breaking Bad this is not a
joke there's a Mexican version of
Breaking Bad and this is the guy who
plays you yeah the Latino remake that
you're talking about is a Colombian
remake not a Mexican one Colombia Mexico
[Music]
maybe gun sorry Connor your Broncos is
the color all right well first of all I
want to congratulate that's real that's
real Wanda doll he made that it
completely himself did all the animation
clearly very talented guy here's the sad
part and one I'm talking to you you're
dead wrong you're just wrong on this one
and to prove it here's my response Oh lo
one as you can see you're not the only
one who can produce cheap animation the
Latino remake of Breaking Bad is a
Mexican remake not a Colombian one sure
it's shot in Colombia with Colombian
actors but it's technically a Mexican
production that's because it's being
bankrolled by Carlos Slim Mexican
business magnate and richest man in the
world I am Carlos Slim I have a burro
made of gold
corn is right I am paying for the remake
of Breaking Bad
just ask my good friend mexico's Salma
Hayek the Latino version of Breaking Bad
he says Mexican Isaac and of Tecate
sorry 1 you're wrong
falooda Jessica Hamby
all real so Liz Lerman the challenge
still stands if you think you've spotted
an error on our show reported at team
koco.com / haha I found an error we'll
sort it out right here on the air let's
see if you've got what it takes to make
chunk meat out of the maestro we'll take
a break we come back ethan hawke is zero
you